yes I know uh new doctors Cameron's
really excited but I think we're all
missing the really big picture here
what's the next sonic screwdriver going
to look like so before I get into it let
me just address the lateness of this
video obviously I would have liked to
have gotten this out sooner but I spent
the weekend helping out a friend because
despite all appearances I do have
friends I do have a life and in a way
I'm kind of glad that I'm a little later
on this because it's given me more time
to like actually think and digest the
announcement rather than just spitting
out a hot take on the casting of the new
doctor but yes I am behind this is a day
review of the first episode of the new
season of Game of Thrones that will be
tomorrow and then hopefully I'm caught
up so the doctor is going to be Jodie
Whittaker who is an actress I don't
really know and once I realize that I
realize I don't I don't actually have a
ton of to say about the casting of her
specifically which bums me out because
that means that pretty much all I can
talk about are the broad implications of
changing the doctor to a woman which I
kind of addressed before but I guess
I'll rehash a few things I will so have
seen her in one thing I saw her in
attack the block I saw that about five
years ago my memory was that she was
very good in it but that's a hazy memory
at this point is not a lot to go off of
I have heard she was very good in
broadchurch which I suppose gives me
another reason to prioritize watching at
the very least the first season abroad
first series abroad Church so that I can
get a better sense of Chris Chibnall as
a showrunner and get a sense of her as
an actress and then maybe I'll have a
better opinion about how she might play
the doctor but unfortunately since I
don't know much about her I got to talk
to broad stuff which and of course the
elephant in the room is that the doctor
is now a woman so I did a video a while
back a couple of years I forget how many
it was like between two and three years
ago I did a video explaining my concerns
about the doctor possibly being played
by a woman now since then I had
basically two major branches of concerns
since then I've softened on one of them
and I'll try if you really want me to go
into detail on that go back to the old
video I'll put a link down below
but short of that i'll rehash it very
quickly here basically my concerns were
initially logistical and then sort of
more philosophical and character
concerned the logistical concern was
that i wanted to have it addressed why
the doctor was becoming a woman now when
he never had before and might hang up at
the time was that we had recently found
out not long before i made that video
that you know the doctor had had thought
he was done regenerating that he thought
matt smith was going to be his last body
so he didn't know he was going to get a
whole regeneration cycle I was kind of
hung up on the ideas like why did he not
become a woman before he burned through
all of his regenerations why now I kind
of still like to see that address if
they can figure out a way to do it
without stopping the story dead in order
to do it but honestly if they never
address that I'll be okay I'll live with
it I've kind of gotten over that one
would still like to see the dress I mean
that's not as big a concern for me now
as it was at the time additionally
though my bigger concern was more having
to do with concerns about the betrayal
and how casting the woman as a doctor
actually you know what I'm not going to
refer to that it's not that the doctor
being a woman was a problem it was that
I had concerns that the doctor no longer
being a man was going to cause some
issues because of some things tied to
the character that I felt were more
inherently normally masculine trait than
I'll explain that a little bit better so
the first point of concern I had was
that I mean I do feel that the doctors
relationship not just with his
companions but like with the universe as
a whole
pretty much everyone he runs into is a
fundamentally paternal relationship
he's usually somewhat emotionally
distant yet protective he wants he can
be harsh but he wants to see the people
around him grow and become better and
develop and I do I do believe that
fundamentally it is a more paternal
relationship and not very much of a
maternal relationship so I didn't want
them to change that dynamic making the
doctor woman suddenly make the character
more maternal rather than paternal I'm
not too concerned that they're going to
do that I think they
and the care I think Chibnall and
everyone else understands the character
well enough to not alter that aspect of
the character and a woman can express
paternal tendencies I think we'll be
okay I again when I did my first video I
had more concerns about a woman
expressing those traits but again I'm
kind of not as the hung up about that
idea now the one thing I am still
concerned about though that I brought up
the last time I talked about this is
that the doctor some of the key traits
of the doctor that are usually at play
and the degree of each of these I'm
going to talk about varies from
incarnation incarnation but I think some
key aspects that are core to the doctor
are deliberate and intentional
subversions of the standard male hero so
your typical male hero in a sort of
sci-fi action II adventure II kind of
story comes in takes charge you know has
weapons fight the the enemies and stands
stand his ground the doctor
by contrast comes in plays the idiot
doesn't use anything that is explicitly
built to be a weapon first and his
primary instinct when confronted with
danger is to run away he may stand his
ground later but his first instinct is
to run away all of these are subversions
and they subvert the expectation of what
we expect out of a standard male hero in
these sorts of situations if the doctor
is not a man we lose that subversion
because you can still keep those traits
and they can be played by anybody and
that's fine but the subversive nature
gets lost because a woman walking into
the same situation doesn't have an
expectation of being take charge using
weapons you know standing ground etc etc
so the fact that the doctor often
doesn't do those things is no longer a
subversion and I think it's kind of key
to Doctor Who as a show and the doctor
the character that the character is
subversive to what is the standard hero
of a lot of these kinds of stories and I
I do feel that it's going to be
difficult to have
doctor and not lose it because basically
there's two options either you keep all
those traits which i think is probably
the better option because I don't think
they should be drastically altering the
character just because it's a woman now
but you keep all those traits but they
lose their subversive flavor or you
alter those traits in which end to
something that would be subversive to a
woman in that situation but then you're
altering core parts of the doctors
character and there's problems either
way so that is sort of my remaining
concern now that said I think the best I
got going to reserve judgment and I'm
not saying well we will lose this
therefore will be bad it's more case of
I don't see a way to avoid losing the
subversive aspects but I do believe that
there is no such thing as a perfect
story there's no perfect narrative
there's no perfect character I don't
mean a character with no character flaws
I mean there's no perfectly written
character but good stories great stories
what they do is their strengths sort of
pave over the falls and the flaws and
they make you not care about them or
maybe even not notice them so it is my
hope that Jodie Whittaker will be so
good in the role and that Cristiano will
be so good at running the show that the
loss of the more subversive aspects of
the character will not bother me because
the show will hopefully do so many other
things wet so this end you know what I
want to address briefly I've been making
a point since the announcement happen of
avoiding Doctor Who message boards and
everything else so I don't know what the
general reaction is I know what the
reaction among my friends is because you
know we we talk can we catch up with
that hey what do you think so but I
don't know what the broad reaction is I
have no doubt that there is at the very
least a small very vocal percentage of
people really shooting off their mouths
about the doctor now being woman here's
the thing I'm going to say to them
because as I said I myself do have some
concerns about the doctor no longer
being a male but here's the thing the
idea the idea that Time Lords can alter
their gender from regeneration to
degeneration was
codified and made canon as a concept
back in the doctor's wife that episode
aired more than six years ago and since
then we had Missy
we had the general in hellbent
reinforcing and reminding you this is
the thing that happens you had six years
to get used to this idea all right and I
get if you still have you know concern
and I even get if maybe you just didn't
want it to happen yet but if you didn't
at least think it was inevitable that at
some point the doctor was going to be a
woman you haven't been paying attention
and you just kept your head in the sand
going so if you couldn't just adjust
yourself so that even you're
disappointed reaction could be civil
over the course of six years come on
but in any case that that's sort of my
general thing I am I am hopeful I like I
said I wanted I want to try and find the
time to watch the first series of
broadchurch now so I can get a better
sense of Jodie Whittaker as an actress
honestly though what I'm much more
interested in one of the much more
curious to see right now is when we get
the reveal of the costume and the look
because I honestly think that's going to
tell us a heck of a lot more about this
incarnation of the doctor than just the
captain does and I'll use the example of
Matt Smith on that when Matt Smith was
person has to be playing David Tennant
and I first saw him like with this
little interview snippet of him saying
oh yeah I'm gonna be the new doctor I
hated him I'm like this is wrong this is
awful then and that's just me looking at
Matt Smith being Matt Smith and you know
it gave me no indication of how he was
going to play and I was just projecting
all this oh this will be terrible
because he'll just be a knockoff David
Tennant then he'll did this that wall of
which was wrong but my expectation
started to shift when the first images
of him came out with that bow tie and
the tree jacket and the suspenders and I
remember seeing that for the first time
going okay and then thinking about it
going alright well that's kind of like
an old you'd expect that look on an
older guy but he's so young that's kind
of interesting
it's a look I would have expected to see
me in the classic era not necessarily in
new who that's interesting and it got me
more in line it started to point me in
the direction of how he was going to
actually play the character and
ultimately I loved Matt Smith as the
doctor he's one of my favorites if not
my favorite it's harder for me this I
know in the past I I did a doctor
ranking board he was at the top I think
to redo that because it's it's a tougher
call for me these days as to who's
number one but he's still right up there
I love Matt Smith so I do think that
getting a look and seeing what the
doctor is going to look like it how the
doctor is choosing tea dresses got to
tell us a heck of a lot more about how
the character is going to be played than
just the fact that it's a woman which
tells us almost nothing honestly which
was why I spent the bulk of this video
talking in these broad philosophical
strokes as opposed to getting into you
know the Nitty Gritty of things cuz you
can't there's nothing to go off of even
if you know her better as an actress
than I do all that tells you is like her
caliber as a performer you know what is
she capable of that still gives you no
indication of how she's going to
actually play this part
so anyone whether they are going oh this
will be the best thing ever because
you'll play it like this or they're
going this will be the earthly a more
custom plate like this they're both
talking out their butts because we don't
know we have no clue how she's going to
play this but we'll get our first
indicators when we see the costume so
that is what I'm going to be keeping an
eye out for once we get a first image of
that I'll probably do a video on it then
because I like that I think there'll be
a lot more to actually substitute lycée
about this new incarnation of the doctor
so new doctor Jodie Whittaker
what are your thoughts whatever they are
and even if you're negative on her can
you at least be civil about expressing
that please I will be happy to hear you
out just don't be a jerk but whatever
your thoughts are drop them down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the poncho
Podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]